mesdames messieurs bon dimanche un
premier rassemblement depuis cinq ans
possiblement le dernier avant les
prochaines élections quelques 4000
libéraux c'était donné rendez-vous cette
fin de semaine à Ottawa pour faire le
bilan des 8 dernières années échanger de
nouvelles idées se mobiliser surtout en
vue de la prochaine bataille électorale
Justin Trudeau qui traîne dans les
sondages embourbé dans les allégations
d'un gérons chinoises a-t-il réussi à
énergiser ses troupes a-t-il réussi à
convaincre ces militants surtout qu'il
pourra barrer la route à Pierre poyièvre
est-ce que le populisme de Pierre
polliath va vous faire voir un médecin
plus rapidement
est-ce que c'est coupures vont aider un
jeune à trouver un logement
est-ce que c'est slogans vont créer plus
d'emplois dans nos communautés non
parce qu'il n'a pas de plan sérieux
les attaques senti à l'endroit de Pierre
Poyet Duclos bonjour bonjour monsieur
Thibault bonjour à tous ceux qui nous
écoutent
ministre fédéral de la Santé vous êtes
au Congrès vous étiez au congrès de
votre partie cette fin de semaine est-ce
qu'il y a une inquiétude est-ce qu'il
suscite une inquiétude chez les
militants
le sentiment qu'on ressent le plus c'est
un sentiment d'énergie c'est
extraordinaire de voir le nombre de
nouveaux membres près de 45% des gens
inscrits au Congrès participent la
première fois un congrès du Parti
libéral beaucoup de jeunes beaucoup
d'ambition c'est extraordinaire parce
qu'on sait qu'on aura besoin de ça qu'on
des prochaines alors que le parti est
loin d'être dans les dans les sphères de
sondage où il était il y a quelques
années monsieur pollièvre il gagne en
popularité il y a des gens qui
l'écoutent son message ça inquiète il y
a des gens qui sont inquiète des gens
puis les gens parlent beaucoup c'est la
plus grande polarisation le populisme le
déplacement de certains autres partis
plus vers la droite à droite que
j'appelle une droite plus crue et plus
cruelle une droite qui est plus dure
envers les gens la société envers le
traitement de l'économie envers la
protection de l'environnement de la
protection de l'air donc c'est une
droite oui qui nous inquiète mais des
gens qui l'écoutent mais oui mais c'est
une base de plus en plus restreinte il y
a beaucoup de conservateurs je dirais
centriste comme nous on est au parti
libérale qui nous écoutent et qui nous
regardent de plus en plus parce que se
sentent exclus de la nouvelle vision que
des propos certainement de nouveaux
chefs du parti consiste à ces
conservateurs plus centrés parce que les
résolutions vous avez débattu et adopter
on pourrait prendre un cahier de
résolution du NPD puis ça ressemble à ce
qu'on y trouverait ça a l'air minimum
garanti quatre semaines de congé qui est
payé l'assemblée citoyenne sur la
réforme électorale qu'est-ce que le
conservateur plus au centre trouve
là-dedans pour venir voter pour vous
comme c'est chrétien hier là j'ai fait
son discours le Parti libéral est
souvent critiquée par les gens de gauche
comme étant trop à droite et par les
gens de droite comme étant trop à gauche
partie libérale c'est un parti
radicalement au centre c'est un parti
très ouvert aussi où toutes les opinions
sont les bienvenus dans un monde où on a
besoin d'être à l'écoute des besoins de
des gens je pense qu'il est la plupart
des gens qui nous écoutent sont plus au
centre des gens raisonnables des gens
responsables c'est malheureusement pas
le discours qu'on entend de Monsieur
poliez mais on dirait on dirait que vous
êtes en 2015 vous êtes assez le parti
c'est un site avantage vers la gauche on
a l'impression que les gens qui se
cherchent une alternative à l'heure
actuelle veulent un retour vers le
centre entre autres au niveau fiscal
peut-être moins au niveau idéologique
mais au niveau fiscal et vous l'offrez
pas ça va arriver un moment donné deux
choses aussi le niveau fiscal et le
niveau sociétal le niveau fiscal on a au
Canada et ça va être encore comme ça
dans les prochaines années pas de
calendrier de retour à l'équilibre
budgétaire je vous signale dans le
dernier budget là c'est surtout
là-dessus que les gens s'accrochent oui
parce que les économistes rappellent
toujours que le meilleur indicateur
qu'il faut utiliser c'est ce qu'on
appelle le ratio d'être PME alors c'est
ça la bonne indicateur et cet indicateur
va chuter au cours des prochaines années
mais d'un point de vue sociétal vous
savez le gouvernement canadien oui il
est effectivement actif mais c'est
important de l'être en 2023 on fait face
à des défis qu'on avait moins au cours
des dernières décennies la protection de
l'environnement la protection de l'air
la protection de la diversité lutter
pour la classe moyenne contre les
inégalités une bonne nouvelle c'est
qu'on a réduit au cours des dernières
années avec la location canadienne pour
les enfants de 50% la pauvreté des gens
mais encore beaucoup de personnes
présentement qui qui ont de la
difficulté à joindre les deux bouts
reconnaître donc les conditions
difficiles dans lesquelles on vit ça
demande une présence et une action du
gouvernement alors vous d'où c'est pas
important c'est pas nécessaire de
réaligner de recentrer ou d'ajuster le
message d'après vous mais il faut
toujours être effectivement recentré il
faut toujours être centré dans les
besoins et les gens et les besoins des
gens bien c'est ce sont des besoins qui
sont à nouveau générés par l'évolution
de l'économie l'évolution des
technologies les changements
démographiques la pression sur la santé
la pression sur la classe moyenne et en
fonction des générations mais les
gouvernements doivent se centrer doivent
s'ajuster bon monsieur paulier a
malheureusement il regarde plus au 20e
et au 19e siècle lorsqu'il remet en
droit en cause certains droits
fondamentaux y compris pour les femmes
lorsqu'il ni l'impact des changements
climatiques sur les catastrophes
naturelles qu'on voit de plus en plus au
Québec et ailleurs au pays ce sont des
choses qui étaient peut-être moins
pertinentes qui avaient ou 30 ans
il y a un intérêt pour son message pour
ne pas l'impression que vous offrez une
réponse j'ai entendu beaucoup d'attaque
dans le courant de la semaine dans le
courant du Congrès mais j'ai pas entendu
le nous on va faire ça à la place ou
nous on va il y a peu d'options les
jeunes de votre partie vous le reproche
le groupe m'aider disent donnez-nous des
choses là des faites-nous rêver il est
où le rêve mais il y a deux types de
politiques qu'on a certes présentement
au Canada il y a la politique de la
colère qui essaie de Monsieur polliève
et la politique de la confiance nous on
sera jamais très bon en politique de la
colère parce que le parti libérale n'a
jamais été un parti de colère de
colérique de haine et de et de
frustration le cas particulier à ne
jamais été un tel partie non plus c'est
nouveau avec cette droite là qui est
plus crue et plus cruelle mais nous on
reconnaît que la confiance c'est une
bonne façon de faire la politique on
peut avoir confiance au Canada on sait
très bien débrouillé au cours des
dernières décennies on a très bien
réussi durant la covid 19 même ça pas
été parfait évidemment et on a au Canada
présentement des mouvements majeur de
positivisme et de confiance qui peuvent
nous amener vers un futur à la hauteur
des attentes des gens un mot rapidement
sur les les derniers développements dans
les allégations dans le cadre délégation
de gérant étrangère là ça parlementaire
Michael qui est visé par ça l'objet de
menace et un diplôme chinois qui est
encore en poste au consulat à Toronto
c'est grave ce qui s'est passé c'est un
élu qui ce qui a été la cible d'un
gouvernement étranger est-ce que est-ce
que vous auriez dû faire vous
gouvernement rien du faire quelque chose
de différent dans ce dossier un c'est
effectivement très grave que ce soit un
parlementaire c'était effectivement
encore plus grave parce que notre
démocratie a besoin que nous
parlementaires puissent
œuvrer librement et au service de leur
concitoyens deux ça relève des services
de renseignement et comme vous le savez
au cours des derniers jours on a demandé
au service des enseignements ce qui
s'est passé pour comprendre pourquoi
s'il existait s'il avait existé des
informations à l'égard de Monsieur Chong
ou à des grands d'autres députés
pourquoi ces informations-là n'avaient
pas été partagées et trois des monsieur
Johnston dans quelques semaines va
déposer un rapport ce rapport va nous
permettre de voir de quelle manière
élargir ses considérations de lutte
contre l'ingérence non seulement de la
part de la Chine mais de la part de la
Russie de la part de l'Iran et d'apport
d'autres menaces qui malheureusement
nous affecte ici au Canada merci
beaucoup